prime minister let's start on an issue
that has dominated this country this
year and continues to do so that of
judicial reforms you've currently put
the reforms on pause whilst you try and
seek a compromise
looking back at the first few months of
this year now do you accept that perhaps
you went a bit too hard a bit too fast
God I could always reconstruct
everything but you don't have playback
you have played forward it seems to me
that we have a situation where there is
a now uh
fairly broad majority that says we have
to reform our judicial system but the
question is how much and how fast and
that is something that I decided in the
wake of the ensuing months to try to get
a consensus I'm not sure we'll govern
it's very hard to get one because in
Israel the uh the judicial arm has
arrogated to itself a lot of the powers
of the executive and the legislature
more than any other place on Earth
and but I don't want to bring it from
one side of the pendulum to the other
side of the pendulum where we arrogate
from the judicial process to the
executive or the legislature powers that
we shouldn't we have to bring it in the
to a happy middle it's going to be very
hard because it's extremely politicized
and often misrepresented so I'm doing my
best I don't know if we'll succeed but
I'm you're sounding quite down beat
about it yeah I'm realistic I'm not
downbeat I'm just realistic you know
because we have I'll tell you what we
have on our side we have
a captain to the team that's me so I can
make an unpopular decision unpopular
among my voters to give it a pause not
to go ahead with everything that we
decided or in fact with anything that we
decided let's give it a pause that was
unpopular but I made the decision on the
other side you have to have some give
some take uh give and take there's no
give because I'm not sure there's a
coherent leadership there it's a
fractured opposition that is uh uh you
know I think not stepping up to the
plate as the Americans saying and I hope
I hope it changes I'm giving it time but
I can't give it infinite time the
proposed reforms at least in their
original form
were unpopular domestically but also
internationally I mean you've taken a
real hit for these if you look at the
shekel I was looking this morning
shackles down more than five and a half
percent against the US dollar since you
won the election back in November
investment in the tech sector the you
know won the Prides of Israel is down 70
percent
q1 this year compared to last year
Moody's have downgraded your rating from
positive to stable they say it reflects
well they've downgraded their the
outlook for Israel they say it reflects
the deterioration of Israel's governance
Fitch have warned that your a plus
rating is at risk your personal polls
have have collapsed well the parcel
there was a poll around Passover that
put one of your opposition Rivals Benny
gants and 51 in new one 34 yeah well
that's not the polls we have but I don't
care about that we just had to go but
the point is it it's been unpopular not
just here where there's been Mass
demonstrations on the streets but the
the Americans have been critical of it
let me now pass back take apart a lot of
the things you said a uh the high-tech
sector is suffering across the world and
there are 80 90 decreases in investments
in in developed countries as well as
relatively okay but everybody is
suffering there's a correction on high
tech that's happening now many things
are happening including the AI which we
could talk about because that's the next
thing that's coming but that's one thing
the next the second thing that you say
there hasn't been any downgrading of
Israel's credit rating our economy is
actually all the commentaries say that
our economy is doing actually very well
our debt to GDP ratio that's how much
debt we have they've revised your
outlook no they haven't agree with that
new designate provides it from positive
to stable well the Outlook is not the
rating number one uh it's important to
understand Israel's economy is very
powerful it's going to remain powerful
because it's a high-tech economy in a
high-tech world and a variable one and
because I led the free market Revolution
which turned Israel from a
semi-socialist economy to a capitalist
economy so I'm not worried about the uh
the shekel down against the dollar very
little that's not a big change it
actually will strengthen today but it's
not important people's pockets it
affects them people can spend no I I
disagree with you I don't think the
economy is the problem I think political
consensus is the problem there's a vast
misrepresentation about what we're doing
and
everybody's adding to the so we're going
to take away the independence of the
Court no we're not I'm not going to let
that happen I said right from the start
after the initial plan was presented I
said
we're not going to have a a sweeping
override capacity of the of the knesset
our legislature against decisions that
the court has the court has sweeping
override decisions over what the
legislator decides but I'm not going to
correct it by having the opposite I want
to move the pendulum to the center it's
a process you get maligned you get
criticized you have to take the Heat and
you know Harry Truman said two great
things he said first if you can't take
the heat get out of the kitchen I can
take the heat I've done reforms I was
attacked I had massive demonstrations
for months I had five months labor stock
when I made Israel into a free market
economy so I'm used to that I think we
need a correction I think it's important
to make that correction in a balanced
way in a responsible way so we establish
re-establish the balance that Israel
enjoyed in its first 50 years between
the various branches of government but
I'm not sure that it's going to be such
smooth sailing right away you have to
take the hits the second thing that
Harry Truman said you know was in
politics if you want a friend get a dog
will you put a timeline a deadline on
the compromise Docs
my children would love a dog would you
put a would you put a deadline on uh on
the compromise talks will you put any
sort of timeline on it or no we're not
putting a deadline they're putting a
deadline on it they're saying you know
you know whatever you do you do the
smallest thing
the uh you know you know breaks up the
talks and I hope I hope they uh
I hope they see the way to finding a
mutually agreeable way to proceed but I
just can't promise you it'll happen if
not if no compromise is found it's back
to the original proposals as we saw at
the start of the year
give me time and let me keep my cards
close to my chest also I have to discuss
this with my colleagues as you know
can I come and say issues regarding the
Palestinians
um figures show that over 7 000
settlement homes have been Advanced
under your government since the start of
the year you know when these are widely
criticized internationally publicly and
privately to you they contravene
international law
you have said in interviews I've seen in
the past that it's the Palestinians that
are the obstacle to peace
as the Secretary of State anti-b Lincoln
said this week its settlements that are
the physical obstacle to peace I think
that's not true and it's not new that I
disagree with this I also disagree that
it's against international law uh
because there's never been an
international decision that says the
Jews cannot lived in Judea that's where
we come from no but ask 49 of the Geneva
Convention says that an occupying Force
cannot build on the land no it cannot
transfer people and build on the land
transfer people build on the land if
it's your disputed military if it's
disputed territory which it is you call
it occupied we call it disputed it's
part of our ancestral Homeland I mean
we've only been attached to it for I
don't know 3 000 years and David
establish our Capital our Capital here
in Jerusalem only 3000 years ago we're
not the belgians in the Congo or the
Dutch in Indonesia for God's sake this
is the land of Israel it's our country
so I I completely disagree with that but
I think one thing is true the
Palestinians are here and we're not
going to push them out we're here and
they're not going to push us out but
that's not the reason that successive
governments okay were unable to make
peace after all they were here they
weren't building they were freezing they
were you know four or five Prime
Ministers who were left of the liquid
and left of me before me and after me
couldn't make peace with the
Palestinians why
because the Palestinians unfortunately
have been commandeered by a leadership
that doesn't want peace with Israel they
wanted peace without Israel they don't
want to stay next to Israel they want a
state without instead of Israel and that
is the real the persistent Palestinian
refusal to recognize the Jewish state in
any border
and the 1967 board building of
settlements
don't run away from what I'm saying
because I'm giving you exactly sure but
if I had your opposite number I'm up
with the bat in front of me I would
obviously scrutinize him in his decision
the answer is you wouldn't I've watched
the uh the Western interviews with Abbas
in there well they were very I have no
one interview with them but um
obviously if you as the Israeli Prime
Minister in front of me and so it's it's
your decisions that I'm scrutinizing and
I mean look at the United States state
department last week described the uh
you know the building of a Shiva in
hamesh in in the West Bank is violating
Israel's commitment to the Biden
admission it doesn't violate any
commitment that is the U.S state
Department well it happens to be wrong I
can disagree with them but the important
thing is what you're saying is that if
for Jew buys private land okay it buys
it and wants to live in the areas next
to the Palestinians that is a criminal
action we have to sanitize ties the area
we have to make it ethnically cleansed
if I said to you the Jews cannot buy
land anywhere in the world in any in
London or Paris and so on you would go
and you would be outraged but the idea
here is that private land in disputed
areas that have not been determined yet
what their political future is the Jews
should not live there because it
obstructs the peace why why do a million
Arabs a million Arab citizens of Israel
live inside Israel and we don't say that
that's not possible on the contrary I
think they're they're allowed to live
anywhere they should have all the Civic
rights equal rights but the idea the
Jews would live next to Palestinians
that obvious the peace I think this
conception is the danger to peace we're
going to have to live next to each other
we'll have to find the political
Arrangement how to do so but the idea
that the presence of Jews in their
ancestral Homeland which has been our
homeland for the last three thousand
years the Jews should not live there it
should be
udenrein jew free I think that's that's
the obstacle to peace
let me talk about what you described as
trying to build a circle of Peace which
is normalization with other countries in
the region a lot of talk that
negotiations are going on with Saudi
Arabia at the moment do you believe a
normalization deal is close with Riyadh
well I certainly hope so but I can't
guarantee it I mean it's up to the
Saudis our hand is extended to all Arab
states and certainly to Saudi Arabia
which is what would you say in the Crown
Prince if you know they scan uses watch
widely throughout the Middle East what
would your message be to them well I I
think that we are
we have great
um opportunities to advance the
peace in our region peace between our
two countries the the well-being Network
peoples but I think it would change
history I mean we have already made one
historic uh Turning Point with the four
uh uh peace treaties of the Abraham
Accords which Israel made under my
leadership with uh UAE United Arab
Emirates with the Bahrain with Morocco
and with Sudan
obviously Saudi Arabia would be a
Quantum Leap Forward because it's the
most
influence on Arab country not only in
the Arab world I think also in the
Muslim world so it would fashion I think
the possibility of ending the
arab-israeli conflict and I think that
would also help us uh solve the
palestinian-israeli conflict because the
Palestinians are only two percent of the
Arab world the reason their leadership
has been resistant to accepting the idea
of a Jewish state is they said well we
have all the Arab world will overcome
Israel one day when they say that the
Arab world has made its peace with
Israel I think they'll there'll be a
turning point also in the Palestinian
politics but I think working outside in
is probably has a better chance of
getting peace with the Palestinians than
trying to bust through the Palestinians
to the Arab world but in a word you're
getting closer to a normalization deal
with Saudi Arabia
I think it's too early to tell but I can
tell you that it's one of the Great uh
goals that I set for myself coming back
to office
um that is to to make to make peace with
Saudi Arabia and the rest of the Arab
world and also to block Iran by the two
by the way the two are interrelated
we'll come on to Iran but first I just
want to talk about the makeup of your
current government which is attracted as
you know
um considerable controversy around the
world you appointed a new advisor this
week who's tweeted in the past that Joe
Biden is unfit for office and he is
slowly but surely ruining America is
that a sentiment that you agree with no
and he is himself said that these are
views that he held as a private
journalist and that is since uh change
his views otherwise he wouldn't be
working for me and aside from everything
else I think Joe Biden is a great friend
of Israel and he's the president of the
United States of America and we work
with him as we work with other
presidents and we have confidence in the
choices that America makes by the way
the con the alliance between America and
Israel has never been stronger the
security cooperation intelligence sorry
you still haven't had an invitation yes
I think it'll come but I think that you
should listen also to what the uh both
the president and the Secretary of State
and the Secretary of Defense and the
Jake Sullivan the National Security
advisor have said the Ironclad Alliance
is exactly that it's Ironclad and it
will continue to be that I mean it's
great to get things we're short on time
your Finance Minister senior figure in
your government said that hawara should
be wiped out he described the
Palestinian people as an invention and
he's been recorded as saying he's a
fascist homophobe do you agree with any
of those statements no and he himself
again said that he was taken out of
context or he uh simply was quoted wrong
but in any case he um I think he
understands that he joined my government
I didn't join his and people
follow our policies and our policies are
responsible okay one of your measures in
your party and very strong and I don't
control every MP one of the politicians
in your party
recently said there are parents who
encourage their children to be lbtq plus
they give a boy a doll because it seems
to them he should be gay
it's a homophobic statement again I mean
ask you again do you agree with that do
you agree with that the homophobic lie
is particularly ridiculous why because I
mean the liquidity is presented as a
liberal party and where the you know
this uh uh you know neo-fascists
whatever they call us okay it's
ridiculous now here's how it ridiculous
the likud has a very active gay cell the
leader of that gay cell happens to be a
liquid knesset member whom I nominated
to be the speaker of the knesset and he
won overwhelmingly across the board from
every liquid member and every one of the
members of my illibial quote Coalition
how come does anybody know that does
your audience know that so they're
trying to paint us as anti-lgbt yeah you
can have a one knesset member who has
those views or two even but the vast
majority have followed my lead they
joined our Coalition we didn't join
theirs the interior Minister again a
very senior Minister recently visited
Alaska compound Temple Mount said we're
in charge here we're making changes
slowly and quietly I mean that is
incredibly incendiary comment to Muslims
to Palestinians and the point is is that
these individuals whether they said this
in the past or recently they are all
part of your government in some form as
ministers or as advisors and this is how
the world and World governments views
your government and when your Finance
Minister Goes to Washington as he did he
didn't get any meetings with the U.S
administrations because they don't want
to deal with him the United Nations the
European Union forgive me Council an
event in Tel Aviv recently because they
didn't want bengaver to talk of this and
you have a problem do you not that a lot
of allies of yours
don't want to engage with major players
of your of your car I think there's an
adjustment period both for the members
of the government and those who are and
for other governments with us the one
thing they have to understand is that we
control policy and we guided for example
on the Temple mount the status quo
sacrosect we're not changing it I don't
care what anybody says we're keeping the
status quo and ultimately over time
people judge it and they see it hasn't
changed and won't change because the
idea that and in fact it's an idea that
has only been possible under Israeli
sovereignty in Jerusalem is that all
three faiths have free and unfettered
access to the Temple Mount where uh and
or to this Church of the Holy Sepulcher
where you have basically the holy sites
of the of the three main monotheistic
phase and that's going to be there
that's a you know that's a I would say a
rigid unchanging principle that I'm I'm
upholding and so will my ministers I
don't care where they come from so you
know people say things people respond to
things people said but look at what we
do and what we do is responsible and
careful and measured I don't want an
escalation of tensions I want to
de-escalate tensions as far as we can
and I want to expand the circle of peace
and I think we can do that for the
benefit of everyone Israelis Arabs
Israelis Palestinians everybody this
week Iran unveiled what it says is a
Hypersonic missile that could hit Israel
within 400 seconds now I don't think
we've seen any public evidence of this
missile do you believe that they now
have that capability
well we're monitoring their capabilities
and I think whatever they have we can
deal with your defense minister recently
said that the threat from Iran is
intensifying and Israel may have to
react
um the U.S Secretary of State to bring
up again said recently we continue to
believe diplomacy is the best way to
verifiably effectively and sustainably
prevent Iran from getting a nuclear
weapon which was you know clearly a
message to you and to Israel
are there any
circumstances where you'd ever consider
talking to a run
I don't know what I'm going to talk to
them about if somebody says we're going
to decapitate you what will I talk about
the method of our decapitation we're
going to destroy you the method of our
destruction I mean Iran is openly
committed to destroying the
the repeating the Holocaust and
destroying the six or seven million Jews
of Israel and we're not going to sit by
idly by and let them do it and also I
don't think that diplomacy by itself
will work I think diplomacy can only
work if you it's coupled with
um uh with a credible military threat or
the willingness to apply that the
military option if deterrence fails it's
just no way to stop any other country
this is how Saddam Hussein was stopped
from building a nuclear weapon this is
how Syria was stopped from building a
nuclear weapon this is how Gaddafi was
stopped not by an action by the threat
of action but there are two countries
left one North Korea there was no threat
and wasn't stopped and you talk to them
all over the place three Americans more
American governments had diplomacy with
them didn't help one bit in Iran well
Iran is we've delayed them by actions
that among other things that I
authorized in my terms of government but
while we set them back at least 10 years
we didn't stop them and they're
progressively moving forward and that's
the danger the real danger is that a
radical Islamic regime will acquire
nuclear weapons and everybody will be in
their sides including Britain they're
getting closer are you on the cusp of
the preemptive strike there was a lot of
talk at the moment that you were getting
closer to having to take military action
well we'll do whatever we need to do to
defend to defend ourselves but I'm not
going to get into any greater detail and
by the way whatever Agreements are made
jcpoa or by other countries with Iran
that doesn't oblige us if they're saying
that they're going to destroy us end
Jewish history after 3000 years 3 500
years of
toiling Under the Sun rebuilding our
homeland reestablishing our national
life here and these ayatulas think that
they could threaten us with a nuclear
Holocaust they were wrong we'll do
whatever we need to do to defend
ourselves
thank you very much thank you thank you